remember a couple months back when Kylie  Jenner and blac Chyna shocked us with it  these pics again  well apparently Kylie's family was  pretty surprised to do we finally get to  see how Khloe Kardashian reacted to  Kylie making nice with her boyfriend at  Tyga as a baby mama on the next all new  Keeping Up with the Kardashians Kylie  and blac Chyna did you forget to tell me  something  I just don't seeing screen grabs from  Twitter and I'm like what this is crazy  how was it you are a beast okay let me  show bye the whole family seems to have  embraced it Chyna now she is engaged to  Rob Kardashian and you know pregnant  with his child we're all in a good place  and I'm happy and we're excited for the  new addition in my family and in their  family